it's a good bet that johnny depp woke up
this morning feeling vindicated but for
amber heard the fight is far from over
welcome to entertainment tonight
nichelle turner is off johnny won over
10 million dollars in damages and now
it's time for his next move
[Music]
new video johnny today waving to fans as
he arrives to perform at a concert in
northeast england
johnny will now apparently join friend
jeff beck for the remainder of the uk
tour
now you have this whole new audience
that is not just interested in johnny
depp as an actor but as johnny depp as a
musician
this was the 58 year old just minutes
after the verdict was read in court he
signed the statement he released to the
press and then posted it on instagram
celebs were quick to show support the
a-list likes on his statement included
jennifer aniston naomi campbell and
paris hilton amber's aquaman co-star
jason momoa liked johnny's post and the
statement amber shared as well the
actress also got a like from selma blair
i think the social media it was like a
roman coliseum
as for the damages amber now owes is she
able to pay a 10.4 million dollar
judgment oh no absolutely not her lawyer
made the rounds with the press adding
amber is planning to appeal legal expert
julie rendellman weighed in she
certainly will have plenty of time i
think she has years to potentially pay
back
what is owed to johnny depp and you also
have to keep in mind you know from the
start johnny depp said this case was not
about money it is possible possible that
the end of the day johnny deppel said
you don't have to give me anything i won
and that's all i need
another question why did johnny lose a
similar defamation case in the uk but he
won in the u.s
amber had an enormous amount of evidence
although a lot of it was suppressed in
this case as opposed to the uk you have
to keep in mind that the uk decision was
against the actual publication it wasn't
against amber heard you have to remember
that what they learned from the uk case
is to demonize amber which is what they
did
and there's another wild twist today
turns out that kathleen zellner one of
the lawyers involved in the hit netflix
series making a murderer was a
consultant for johnny she told the law
and crime network he called her after
watching the show he said i saw him
making a murderer where you said that
you'd be the last person someone would
hire if they were guilty
because you would find out about it and
that i was very struck with that but
that's what motivated him i provided
moral support for him and also i really
enjoyed getting to know him we all
believed in him
[Music]
you